the jurogan experience nobody
thought i was gonna lose except for one
guy
one guy actually said i can beat him
but he didn't tell me he forgot to tell
me so i didn't take him for granted i
took him for granted and so
i always went through routines warming
up getting ready
mentally we weighed in five hours before
a match
from then on you ate and drank a little
bit and then focus
focus rest focus focus i was doing
interviews
with wide world sport
right during the national finals and i
wasn't the talker like i could talk
pretty good now
because i learned to talk but at that
time
off the mat i couldn't talk to anybody
and so when they put a mic
in front of me and they wanted to know
about
hey can you just say this say hey i'm
dan gable
come watch me next week on wide world
of sport as i finished my career
182 and 0. and i hadn't wrestled the
match yet
and so i i was supposed to say that but
you think i could say that
hell no i couldn't say that i kept
stuttering
not saying it and they kept redoing it
so finally after about
15 takes they wrote it out on big cards
and so i took about seven takes with
that one i think i got it done in about
22 takes but then i
when i got it done it wasn't good either
they just finally said oh that's good
enough get out of here
so i turned i'm on deck
i'm on deck so they already went through
the 118 126 134 i was 142 at that time
so 134 is just uh wrestling
and i always warmed up for you know a
good 45 minutes to an hour
so i hit a quick warm-up and went out in
that match and
i and i didn't realize there was
somebody that actually thought they
could beat me
and even though before i always did the
routine i went through it but
i'll tell you what you skip once you're
vulnerable for only time in my life that
within a minute into the match
i could hear the crowd a minute into the
match
i could feel how i felt
and i was feeling tired and weak
i mean i never knew how you felt in a
wrestling match until the match was over
and once it was over yeah sometimes i
felt good
but sometimes i felt weak and tired but
i didn't show it because i
didn't think about it i didn't know it
but the one time he didn't prepare
any guy thinking that he could go with
you
and he could you know you
you you take on everything so you take
on way more than just your opponent
and so i talked myself into wrestling
after minute one
i kept saying i gotta i gotta keep going
i gotta keep working hard and so i got
an early lead
just a quick first take down
but i kept feeling how tired it was and
i kept hearing the crowd
why do you think you were so tired
because i didn't warm up
i was doing talking i was not focusing
on my math concentration no warm-up had
that much of an effect on your
conditioning
i used to be a a pretty well even today
as you get older
you notice how if you don't warm up and
you hit something really hard
you get you get exhausted and it's
probably kind of like
that uh usually what i did for warm-ups
is probably
with within a half hour of my match i
would get
match heartbeat rate up and go for
three or four minutes that way so now
you don't get real tired
but then after that you'd probably have
a little drink and
get ready to go what would you do for a
warm-up you had a very specific routine
pretty much pretty much um you know
stretching
and jogging and then actually wrestling
actually wrestling pretty hard and uh
to to where you would actually sweating
good and and then
i actually got to the point where if i
had a lot of time before my match i
would actually go take another shower
but usually when you were the fourth guy
out or something
you just kind of stayed loose but you
didn't really
and then right before your match again
you might get your heart rate up again
to uh because your heart rate didn't
really go down below 100 probably
and you need it in a wrestling match
it's probably going up to 170 180 you
know stuff like that
and but you wanted to have your heart
rate up to your
that match pace heart rate for not seven
or eight minutes because that you're
gonna
gonna be not gonna recover quick enough
you'll still be tired you wanna be tired
so you'd get it up there and spike it up
and down for two or three minutes and
hitting some really good execution of
wrestling holds we do hand fighting a
lot of hand fighting
and that hand fighting can really uh can
get that heart rate up and pushing and
shoving and
hitting some live techniques where the
guy was letting you do it but you're
doing it
at live pace and you do some sprints and
do some tumbling gymnastics tumbling
but in this match no warm-up at all
when i got done with the 22nd take of
the of the of the
of the uh and i was the net i had that
match to warm
up so i i probably had 10 minutes
instead of my normal
45 minutes or so but i thought i was
still ready
and but it was something out of my
control
actually and it took took me over but i
did talk my way into uh
because i got a head but then i got real
far behind
i mean i was behind by six points
and then i got ahead by uh
two or three points and that was right
towards the end of the match
and then there was a flurry
could have went either way but the
referee went his way
and that's the way it is i mean
it's just it's just that's calls does
that haunt you to this day
of course it haunts me but guess what
i needed that loss
i really did that loss took me to
unbelievable heights that i would have
never had without that loss
what's unbelievable is if you ask the
guy that beat me
larry owings he said if i had to do it
over again i might have lost that match
on purpose
or not even on purpose just because i
didn't know how to handle it
i wanted to be an olympic champion i
wanted to be a world champion but when i
won that match there was so much hype i
didn't know how to handle it
he said even broke up my marriage
he was married again that's what he
claimed catch new episodes of the joe
rogan experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background by using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost all
for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience